[Musik] Die Nachricht ist also, dass der Präsident das Krankenhaus verlassen wird. Was ist Ihre Reaktion? Ich bin begeistert darüber, dass das bedeutet, dass es
ihm gut geht,
wenn er das Krankenhaus verlässt. Ähm, wir sind
aus Baltimore, Maryland,
ich habe meine mitgebracht  Mann und meine Tochter
hier
ähm und ähm, wir sind hauptsächlich hier, weil
wir nicht wollen, dass die Vereinigten Staaten ein
sozialistisches Land sind
, das ist unser Hauptgrund, warum
ich verstehe, dass der Präsident
in das Weiße Haus zurückkehrt, das
er gründen wird  seine Wiederwahlkampagne noch einmal,
uh, was bist du, hoffst du, dass er
wird, du weißt, gewinnen,
ja, ja, ich bin, ich sehe die ganze Begeisterung
für diesen Mann
schnell schnell noch eine
andere frage der präsident sagte
in seinem tweet äh hab keine angst vor kobet
ist das so wie du es siehst
ja ich habe keine angst damit fertig zu werden ich habe überhaupt keine
angst
die überlebensrate ist hübsch  Hoch
, weißt du, also danke, danke, und wir
lieben Donald  trump wir lieben unseren präsidenten
wir lieben unseren präsidenten vielen dank julie
der präsident
[musik]
b
ausländisch
[musik]